london-born actor Robert Pattinson
skyrocketed to fame with a massively
popular Twilight series and he recently
made headlines when it was announced
he'd be playing the titular role in the
Batman and from modeling gigs to his
sometimes dramatic love life here's
everything you need to know about Robert
Pattinson after honing his craft in
several theater productions Robert
Pattinson landed his first big break at
the age of 17 he was cast as Cedric
Diggory in the 2005 film Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire moment Ashley she
we're gonna let it get me
he chose playing Cedric over attending
University and the film took his acting
career to a whole new level his
performance was widely praised and
numerous publications hailed him as the
next Jude Law a label that proved
difficult to shake in a 2008 interview
with the BBC Pattinson was asked whether
he agreed with that assessment and he
replied no you get a bit of heat and
everybody says you're this you're that
then it dies down you just do jobs I
don't know any actor who's followed
through when they say he's the next this
and then he actually has become the next
that I don't get that I don't see what
the point is the fourth Harry Potter
film put Robert Pattinson on the map but
Twilight turned him into a household
name
Pattinson landed the role of Edward
Cullen in a rather roundabout way he was
in Los Angeles auditioning for a role he
assumed was already in the bag and wound
up bombing that audition in 2017 he told
W Magazine and then the next day was the
toilet audition and I think I was it
such a kind of nothing to lose state
it's quite easy to do and so he was cast
as an unusually sensitive vampire who
falls in love with a young woman named
Bella portrayed by Kristen Stewart the
role earned him legions of fans many of
them teenage girls but that didn't stop
him from mocking the Twilight franchise
in interviews my entire performance is
based on the have extreme discomfort the
content of your eyes is this kind of
Edward was not a fictional character
who's met him and
you know he's one of those guys who'd be
like an axe murderer he also wasn't
opposed to mocking Stephenie Meyer the
author of The Twilight novels I was
convinced that Stephenie was convinced
she was Bela and I knew it wasn't it was
like it was a book that wasn't supposed
to be published
it sounds like Pattinson has softened
his stance in recent years in April 2009
teen he told USA Today
it's lovely now that the mania is not so
intense now the intensity has died down
and it's just very warm memories in May
2009 teen it was announced that Robert
Pattinson would play a young incarnation
of a certain brooding superhero in the
Batman
a film that's set to premiere in 2021
rather predictably the news sent the
Twitterverse into a frenzy and not
everyone was on board with the idea one
user wrote I've never been so
disappointed in a Batman casting Robert
Pattinson is a horrible choice to play
the character film critic Mike
McGranahan was clearly torn by the
casting choice tweeting I honestly don't
know how to feel about Robert Pattinson
his Batman on one hand I hate the idea
because I can't even remotely picture
him as The Dark Knight on the other hand
I absolutely loved the idea for the
exact same reason meanwhile Jimmy Kimmel
offered this particularly hot take if
you think about it it makes sense he was
a vampire now he's a bad in 2012
Robert Pattinson 'he's relationship with
kristen stewart turned him into
irresistible tabloid fodder though they
tried to keep the relationship under
wraps they were forced to come clean in
the wake of a highly publicized scandal
Stewart finally acknowledged their
relationship after she was photographed
being intimate with then married
director Robert Sanders who worked with
Stewart on Snow White and the Huntsman
when a famous actress gets caught
cheating by the paparazzi and then makes
a very public apology it's no surprise
people everywhere are reacting with 140
characters or less Stewart profusely
apologized in a public statement writing
this momentary indiscretion has
jeopardized the most important thing in
my life the person I love and respect
the most Rob I love him I love him I'm
so sorry
Stewart and Pattinson briefly got back
together after the scandal but they
split for good in 2013 in 2019 Pattinson
suggested that he's on good terms with
Stewart so perhaps this story has a
happy ending after
roll with his chiseled features it's not
terribly surprising that Robert
Pattinson would try his hand at modeling
he told closer magazine that he left the
industry after four years at the age of
16 explaining when I first started I was
quite tall and looked like a girl so I
got lots of jobs because it was during
that period where the androgynous look
was cool then I guess I became too much
of a guy so I never got any more jobs I
had the most unsuccessful modeling
career in 2010 at the height of Twilight
Beaver Pattinson was reportedly offered
a huge contract with Burberry but he
didn't take it a source told the mirror
they went to Robert but he immediately
politely turned them down as far as
Robert sees things he's an actor by
trade and that's his art he doesn't want
to start becoming a brand or anything if
that's true Pattinson obviously had a
change of heart just a few short years
later in 2013 he became the face of dr
ohm and he's been working with the brand
ever since
as it turns out Jude Law was the face of
dr own just a few years prior
which means robert pattinson became the
next Jude Law after all
well Kiko better than me check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]